were your thoughts on ali on ali wong
so
um
yoshi had mentioned that i shouldn't
have started with her third one because
it was so dirty
right
but all of them
are um
[Music]
they don't quite open with money shots
on your face like her third one
um
but dirty does not mean it's it's not
funny at all and what a few things i
found
interesting just in themes throughout
where like there's she has like a
hip-hop to her she has like a swag to
tour there's a definitely a hip-hop vibe
with everything she does
which you know as white boy joe you know
i mean that that's that's joel bzee a
day a day
yeah i mean
um
she would she also like i know we're
talking about her final special but i
hadn't seen any of them so it's like she
also there's like a connection to each
one and she kind of references things
from the first
into the next and whatnot which i think
is an interesting thing
that
comedians could think about in their own
comedy specials like mikey winfield
has a few specials and we had him on the
podcast and he was talking about how he
did make it like each one is like a
chapter in his life that leads into the
next so
that could be a way to do specials i
know people in like
the uk
they do more specials that are theme
based and it's like i'm just doing a
special about my dad or something and
they just do a singular focus
in america it's kind of like a
free-for-all you know but
if you can create kind of a story arc
between each comedy special i think i
think there's an opportunity to create
lifelong fans
that make it also more shareable
um
but overall
i think i mean she's hilarious and her
physicality is something i didn't
when i tried to watch the third one with
my wife the first time
i was just blown away by the first 20
seconds there was a money shot joke and
i was just like oh boy
but when you actually get into it her
performance and her facial expressions
and how long she holds them
like it's it's another level so i i i'm
very glad that you guys uh pushed me to
watch all of them so we could do this
breakdown because yeah her especially
her facial expressions and how she holds
stuff and she's like she's a she's like
smaller but she fills up that entire
stage with her performance yeah
yeah
that's a good breakdown i mean
i think in watching the first special i
watched the third one again
like the storytelling
of her life
and how she does bring it back to like
the first thing
i thought was one of the best things
i've ever seen like a comedian do
because you watch her struggle through
realizing who she now is as this mega
superstar
which i thought was like just dope so
you're actually watching someone talk
about the struggle
of becoming this thing that they didn't
want to be necessarily
but now that they are and they've come
to grips with it so that was like you
know it's it's it's kind of meta but
it's like
i love watching it on as tags and jokes
and all these other things
and like just
in each of her special her
closers
i think have been like phenomenal
like they're just so
well
crafted because they bring in
everything that was said
before in the set yeah so her composers
have like these amazing call back
ability i don't even know if that's a
word we'll just
we'll just trademark that but her
callback ability is amazing
yeah i don't know if you heard the
beginning of the show joel named a whole
new city that doesn't exist
we make up words here
[Laughter]
minneapolis it's like it's where the
minions are from
from that movie despicable me that's
where the minions are from is mini
minneapolis yeah minneapolis
[Laughter]
yeah you're right though
you're right
uh i did want to give a shout out to the
guy from the dominican republic that's
where i'm from
yo isn't that dope that is that's
awesome
you know what's really crazy is i've
been getting hit up um for comedians to
for me to break down their stuff
what
yeah randomly they'll send me something
say hey what do you think of this
no
you're becoming what
yeah it's been pretty cool
and we've only done it twice yeah
and fyi i'm a nobody in this comedy game
i just want to make sure
[Music]
you about to be if you keep talking like
that i'll tell you that right now fam
we in the growth mindset here at the hot
breath verse
none of that negative self-talk shawty
steve just said you're the money ball of
comedy let's not get it twisted fam
they're new to this you grew to this fam
yeah uh you deserve to be here fam say
it i deserve to be here the only thing
is that my baby
i believe in myself my name is chris and
i am important and i do man
and i should be here
my bank account doesn't reflect the
money ball portion of this yet though so
yet as he said see we're rubbing off on
him yoshi he said yet
yes uh
one thing i liked about the ali wong
special and uh
newer comedians should study this is the
stage presence
she
that stage was huge
and she owned it
like it was a small venue
yeah you could tell even by the way she
was walking around just had confidence
like it was through the roof and i
really enjoyed it i liked i liked her
presents
her facial expressions selling the joke
um but now and this is what i wanted to
ask you guys
if
a laugh
is
is if she gets a laugh
and it stays at the same level
volume wise and adds a tag to it
that's considered two laughs
right
like if she says something and then it
goes to another
the same way
oh yeah yeah that's another laugh
because she says something to continue
it that continues to wave right right
that's what it is and that's how it is
yeah i mean really that's just she's
just tagging on top of it but i know
what you're talking about she does
there's a moment where she's like
waiting for it to die down and
i don't think she wrote it in her
special i think she instantly went
somewhere else
and then added it live
like that's what it felt like it felt
organic it didn't feel like she wrote it
down because even she recognized
that oh this is different
and i'm going to give you a number that
is going to blow your mind
18 applause breaks
then that's special 18
so i'm not surprised dude
i'm not surprised that's how many
applause breaks she got in this special
now
breaking down the special
there was only 301 laughs in the 57
minutes that she was on stage
yeah
so yeah here's the thing 5.2 glass per
minute
i studied her first comedy special
and
you can find scripts on like how many
words people use
um
and in baby cobra
i think it was
um
like in baby cobra although she she did
like an hour i compared it to um
what's the roy woods jr special
she used about 75
less words
than
roy woods jr's actual special she
doesn't say
a lot
because
she's getting a lot of
applause breaks
in between
her content and she waits
for the
laughter to die down before she says
anything else
versus somebody like earthquake that
hits on it hits on it hits earthquake
doesn't give you time to calm down he's
like i'm gonna hit you in the mouth once
more yeah if you're an asthmatic at an
earthquake show you need your inhaler
because you will have an asthma
i love how he is the barometer of
everything it's like
it's how many earth on a scale of five
earthquakes how many earthquakes is this
but this is why we were we this is why
we geeked out on the earthquake special
so much right we had 334 laughs in 30
minutes
and she got 300 laughs and 57
but yeah 18 applause breaks so there was
a lot of
gaps
but uh this i think the special was dope
uh
i i when i saw the number when i did the
number i didn't feel like
what i saw and the numbers that i got
they didn't feel the same
because the special
continued and it it flowed very well
i bet and i'm no i'm i'm geeking out on
this math though i bet if you counted
how many words were actually said
and compared it to words like per
minute kind of thing and then the laughs
in that i bet it'd be about the same
because she just doesn't use a lot of
words and earthquake is also a fast
talker
yeah right ally wong is slow
just like
she's more steady in like the way that
her speech is much more steady
earthquake is like boom boom boom boom
like very conversational quick hitter
kind of thing
i bet if you were to study that it's
different but i like the fact that
you know
i didn't i didn't it didn't feel like
she was not getting laughs throughout my
set
like right i was like oh this is funny
all of that was funny it just hit you
to get a clear shot of of what we said
57 minutes on stage 57 minutes and 50
seconds
301 laughs
18 applause breaks
and 5.2 last per minute that's still a
laugh every 12 seconds
yeah yeah that's what i was just doing
the math on is how many that is still
and that i mean that's that's still a
crazy pace for an hour
crazy pace and you don't want to include
the applause breaks oh that's true and
the 18 applause breaks cause i i wasn't
watching it thinking
oh there's a bit of a lull here or oh
i'm surprised she's not getting more
laughs like it's killer throughout but
it is also a style thing that
earthquake is just coming in like an
earthquake he's going to destroy you
until someone dies and then leave you
know allie it is just more drawn out and
it's a completely different style but
both are funny and that is interesting
yeah a little over five laps a minute i
didn't even notice
but that's still a ridiculous pace every
12 seconds you're getting a laugh 12
seconds try that comics
so
go ahead and try ally with ali what i
found was
the fact that she was herself
and didn't cater
to someone else's style of comedy
so she's when she's on stage she's more
like this is me
this is who i am
either accept it or don't i'm not going
to change who i am and you can see that
in the three specials she's always been
this way
and with the money shot in the first
minute i was like all right we're here
now right now 58 minutes
um but there was one joke that stood out
to me the most
it was
having kids
uh having a play date with kids
is the same as having a blind date set
up by your toddler and that to me was
such a funny idea
i just i i that that one stood out to me
it made me laugh
yeah that's a really unique point of
view i guess you both have kids so i
guess that rings true
yeah yeah cause play dates i mean my my
daughter has a
a friend that she's good friends with
uh but if
we didn't get along with the parents we
would still hang out because she likes
being around her friend we don't want to
break up
the friendship luckily we get along with
everybody because i mean i am who i am
you know what i mean i mean you're a
boss you've been on chocolate sundaes
you've met kevin hart i haven't i
haven't mentioned it once i have not
mentioned it once
because you mentioned it half of the
other episodes i think yeah i made up
for it for the other times
[Laughter]
you ran the light talking about meeting
cat williams that's what you did yeah
that's what i did
there's definitely uh a flex in every
episode
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna grab some water
real quick no you're good shouty yeah
are you good and it looks like um shorts
for change said
james a caster's repertoire is the
pinnacle
of this i think maybe the thematics of a
comedy
special um i i haven't watched any of
his have you guys watched me james a
caster
hey joel what
look at you boy
looks like a hot breath water commercial
hold on
small flex for the for the for the promo
for the for the group here yeah yeah i
love that how funny
i don't have anything
today don't worry about
i was telling i was telling uh joe it
looked like your internet was from
kosovo last week you froze like crazy
[Laughter]
my guy spliced it from his neighbor
that's what he's doing out there
you don't know you don't know about
these fortnite kids they using them all
oh yeah
that's strange when they take up the
stream
it's no joke like i'm like oh yeah kids
uh get off the internet so daddy can
work
yeah
should there be
so we we wanted to use these breakdowns
as a way to
uplift people and such but do we have
any
like is there a way to like grade these
not grade but like
give us
what does hot breath say about
ali wong's special do we have like
criteria if we're gonna keep doing this
this is
this is what i felt about the the set
and there's something unique about all
the ones that we've done already right
but
what i took away most from this set
was um
to be yourself
the stage presence
how to sell the joke with the facial
expressions
uh
not stepping on your laughs
letting the laps
come and uh
giving yourself time there's a lot of
pauses
giving yourself time to be in the pause
because as a newer comedian you're very
uncomfortable in the pause
she said a lot of shocking stuff
but it was it wasn't to get a reaction
it was telling her story
whereas a newer comedian will just say
shocking stuff just to say
shocking things just to get a a reaction
and
um she's a good storyteller
and i feel
i i feel
if you're if you're gonna learn
something from ali wong
the joke writing and storytelling the
stage presence
and the fact that she
was engaged with the audience throughout
like you can tell that she was looking
directly at people she wasn't
uh
uncomfortable in her set in any way
um so yeah
that that's what if we were to continue
doing that that's what i that's what i
do with these sets i take
the personal parts of it
and
that that's what i take away from it
earthquake was a great stage presence
but he was also a great tagger he did a
lot of storytelling but he picked up all
his laughs at the end of this at the end
of the punch line with a ton of tags
um taylor tomlinson was very personal
with her
battle with therapy depression bipolar
very personal stories ali wong was more
about the stage presence she had an aura
about her
the
facial expressions the the
what i noticed was that she would do
something where she would like
give it that pause and then hit you with
the punch line and it gave it that
bigger
that that that well i think it was you
that taught me this joe where you wait
for the tension and then you pop it with
the punch line but that punch line has
to pay off
yeah
and yeah she paid it off in that in that
in that set for sure
yeah it's like the it's like the the
longer you go between laughs like a
picture like a balloon filling up so the
longer you go between a laugh the bigger
that laugh better be at the end of that
silence
so right
yeah and allie does a great job of that
and i i agree i think her
it's so funny her physicality is the big
thing i took away just even like lifting
up her dress i mean she just she just
commits
a hundred percent
to what she's talking about she just
commits and delivers
and even if it's a big act out like her
showing her panties
over and over again or it's just a
facial expression and a pause that she
does like her physicality is unmatched
and that that's the big thing i took
away is just the confidence in her
performance what was it george carlin
that said if uh if you want to get a
laugh after something serious raise your
eyebrows
eyebrows breaks
oh
i think it was george carlin that said
that but uh allie wong does that in the
set where you can see that she says
something crazy and then her eyebrow
raises and then that gets the laugh
another thing that stood out was that
she wore glasses
and uh
i was always told never to cover your
face
uh with a hat with glasses because then
you hide
the expressions
and it could it could be a problem
selling the joke
and ralphie may does this in his in his
youtube master class that he has out
uh where he talks about all that stuff
yeah
i was trying to think um i was reading
the comments here
but yeah i know glasses i don't know
glasses as much but definitely like hats
can cast a shadow and such yeah hats
will cast a shadow um i was thinking
also
in sort of the
breakdown her
physicality
in the way that she uses the entire
stage she definitely uses a stage more
than the other two people she went from
left to right
and was physical in all different spots
she also did something that i think
chris rock does
is where she tells jokes to different
sides of the room throughout her entire
set
like she would pick the side of the room
tell them the joke go to the middle tell
them a joke go to the other side tell
them a joke and just like moved to the
one and she just kept moving all the way
through because she has such a presence
um
on stage the other thing i really liked
about her
just her overall
kind of like in the way that her
content is
she really talked about being
comfortable being successful
which i think is a hard thing to do as a
comic and i think she pulled it off
really really well
of just like
she did a lot of flexing like if we were
like backstage at our show we were like
you know you just gonna talk about the
specials you just go talk about how rich
you are you just gonna talk about
your your your husband and you know how
dope he is like she's just it was a lot
of flexing you mean yeah but
she comes off as very genuine even
though she's flexing
on how dope she is as a person and i
love yeah she didn't disconnect with the
with the crowd right yeah because it's
authentic exactly yeah it's very very
authentic
i don't know if you guys have seen the
the
uh interview that jerry seinfeld did
with jamie foxx
on comedians in cars getting coughing
uh in the special jamie foxx said that
he knew that he was out of touch when he
got on stage and he started talking
about the newest range rover and the
specs in the newest range rover and
no one laughed
and then
chris tucker got up there
and destroyed the crowd and when he
heard that roar
he like brought him and humbled him and
he's like man i don't know what the hell
i did wrong but he went and he went and
revisited the set and changed everything
about it scrapped it
yeah it's true
yep
yep but i got a i got a challenge for
you guys that uh it was brought to me i
wanted to see what you guys think okay
rating
the kings of comedy
to see who the real king was
based on last minute i don't think
that's that much of a challenge to be
honest i already know who it is
but we could break it down
i actually personally don't think that's
really like a challenge or a hard thing
what do you mean
the original kings of comedy between who
you got bernie mac said
dl
and the other guy
oh absolutely no that's not a that's not
a it's bernie mac
yeah absolutely there's no
this
what were you going to say chris
but uh based on laughs per minute we can
we can see it's true and steve harvey i
just said the other guy because we made
that
joke probably the first time we did this
show we were making steve harvey jokes
and i was like oh he's never going to
come on the podcast now
but
or breaking down a classic like uh eddie
murphy raw
yeah yeah i like
i like
i don't see what's wrong with
looking at the last per minute of the
kangs
like
yeah we can say it's bernie mac but what
does the math say
right yeah i mean you could do this was
a good step but
[Music]
you can do the math but ain't no
question like here's here's i remember
telling somebody this today
like
and even everyone who's on that kings of
comedy special i don't know if you ever
saw like any kind of background on them
will tell you
they will never follow bernie
no
they wouldn't they were like
they're like who's going last oh
bernie's going last
if he was to walk in the room i don't
think there's a lot of people
even given like i don't think dave
chappelle can follow bernie mac
like there's just some people that you
just cannot
follow
right and i think that's like
i think even even somebody like a cat
williams
it's hard to follow cat williams
you mean like there's just some people
that walk in a room like that even if
they're not like considered like
top of the
top of the food chain in terms of like
comedians who are like the best
i have a hard time believing there's
comedians today that can follow
a bernie mac or
a cat williams or an earthquake
like that's
like regardless of the list right yeah
yeah it's hard who do you think could
have followed that earthquake special
we still haven't found anybody that
could even get close
no
yeah i mean
like
and that was 30 minutes who who's got
enough gumption to go after 30 minutes
of what earthquake did in a set to be
left i got this there's not a lot of
people but i don't i don't hate the idea
of
like like breaking down all the kings
and then being able to rank them
like based on who got laughs per minute
i like that as
that's not that's not bad i mean
i'm just saying you can do the math
but there's no doubt
who the king of comedy is
i think it would just be an interesting
discussion
yeah somebody in the comments said uh
jesselnick is arguably the best written
comic currently but even though he does
one-liners his styles is so slow and
just makes laughs per minute are low
but he has that style where he has that
tension and then pops it with that huge
punch line
but also justin nick is one of those
people that i think this might be
something we gotta factor into
you gotta factor how many words people
use
to actually get for the last because
just
doesn't use a lot of words to get
the laughs
he's probably using the same amount of
words that other comedians are
but his are long and drawn out
but he's hitting you
slowly
like that minute might be drawn out and
he's getting one laugh but that one
laugh like you said is an applause break
because he built the tension for so long
i can count his words i mean it'll take
me a while but i'll break down jail next
time
script we can just find the script on
that
oh yeah there's a script on a lot of
comedy specials out there i think
i think there's a resource i forgot what
it was called we linked it in our
facebook group a while ago remember
there's like a website that has like all
of them
i wonder if ali wong's is in there
for
a cobra special i don't think i sent it
to you chris but there's this
great breakdown of ali wong's baby cobra
special that was like so scientific i
said to joel and joe's like what in the
hell is this but it broke down the
topics
and it broke down when certain topics
matched together
to get
laugh breaks so they broke down themes
all the way through of her entire baby
cobra special it was dope
it was very scientific you definitely
love it
yeah i would i want to see i wonder
because i wonder how many words she used
versus taylor tomlinson
because they had the same amount of time
on stage
and taylor had seven last minute
so yeah so the the options would be the
kings
doing a classic
of whoever
or uh doing another new special that
jeff foxworthy just dropped one
yesterday
oh jeffy boy dropped frog
yeah that was on the list that we wanted
to do too we should do jeff's i love the
idea of the kings and of doing like
classic ones
um yeah but yeah let's do jeff's next
okay
we can do that
so you'll be out first
i'm really excited about his
because when you had him on the podcast
and he said
um when my wife and i watch a movie i
write punch lines i write jokes
and he had like
how many notebooks did he show
oh my gosh dude there's so many it was
like a whole desk full of notebooks and
he was like oh this was just last week
yeah
it was crazy
yeah he's awesome he's so prolific
people get caught up in the the tagline
but he's done a lot dude
yeah extremely prolific and despite you
know
having more money than the federal
reserve i still feel like he doesn't
in the comedy world it's like oh he's
the you might be a redneck guy he's done
so much more
oh look at that
she's drinking hot breath water
getting them young getting them on it
young there chris i see
yeah we'll do jeff foxworthy next uh i'm
i'm really excited to break his down
because i saw uh larry the cable guys
special
and
um just the amount of tags that he does
on the end of his jokes man it was
insane incredible
he's a machine gun too
so
another idea is
i like no let's do jeff but i mean
down the road it's like we can do the
kings and rank them and we could do the
blue collar people and rank them
yeah that would be a good one too doing
the blue collar ones yeah
um but we'll do because there's also the
uh the
latin kings of comedy is another one
oh yeah paul rodriguez on it
uh george lopez is on that one too
the philippe esparza special the last oh
yep
dude
that dude was a machine
when it comes to jokes per minute
like
it's impressive yeah
and and he flipped it and did it in
spanish
and it translated just as just as well
and all that
i want to do a special in spanish
i just need to learn spanish
[Laughter]
seems easy enough let's see
ah mason minnows
see it's one of the fastest way
just a word of advice to newer comedians
don't take every gig if you can't speak
spanish don't take a gig in spanish and
try to do it
it's going to be really bad for you
don't do it
oh dude i did
i did an all spanish show
it was a midnight
show
all spanish and four people showed up
so to bomb in a language i don't speak
um
in front of a
room that holds like 200 people had four
people it was very um very insightful
humbling how do you say humbling in
spanish
so the question is brought up have we
ever done a top five
or ten comics right now
no
i don't uplift everyone we try not i
think i think it's too difficult to do
because that's all based on opinion
like the lists get clicks
people saying top ten like whenever
variety drops a new list like oh my god
the
comics to see and i feel like hot breath
could do that
but yeah i like uplifting and like
just giving people they flowers as we
say yeah yeah and we're trying to keep
our breath alive if you do a top 10 no
one's going to want to do an interview
with joel because he never made that
list
yeah oh my god
dailon died
yes
i love it
awesome
well dude
good stuff man i i'm not yeah
i think so like
from this last per minute we're doing as
a
a gauge
but that doesn't mean
that the special was bad
or in any way she she's a killer on
stage i would hate to follow her
um
i just wouldn't follow her i'd just be
like
i'm good
that was great
that was a great show
[Laughter]
yeah i mean after after the money shot
on the face i'm going to talk about my
kids
how do you how do you follow that
yeah you can't
so jeff jeff foxworthy is next
early next week
nice
all right
i'm very excited about that one
and i love the discussion in the chat
two people talking about it so we thanks
for hanging out hot breath the verse
yeah this is dope
and uh
i think did you guys do the joke right
now
yeah we're gonna do some joke breakdowns
um yeah i saw some um
that need more than breakdowns yeah
magdalena was
having a bit of a moment there she was
like wait where's where are our joke
feedbacks this is cool
but where is our what about us
what about us
[Music]
it's all good
so
uh are you guys are you guys doing any
shows this weekend
yes
in minneapolis
no it's in atlanta
[Laughter]
and minneapolis
indianapolis
[Music]
i have to read it twice but when you put
it up i was like there's not another n
in there is it
typical of a white man adding an n you
know trying to
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've been called michael sarah i've
taken a photo as michael sarah
that was so funny i was at the laughing
skull i saw pete holmes who kills
and and then someone came with me
afterwards like oh my gosh can i have a
picture
and i mean you know i'm a comedian i was
like well of course i'm a famous
comedian and then they were like i loved
you and super bad like they were being
completely serious
and i just took the photos if i was
michael sarah so there's a photo of me
floating around out there where someone
tagged that they were with michael sarah
and then all their friends are like uh
maybe like the android version of
michael sarah i don't think that's the
4k version
my uh my daughter called me a potato
with eyebrows so i guess
and she's she's not wrong
she's not wrong
[Laughter]
i i guess i look like mr potato head to
her so
oh my gosh that's hilarious yeah anyway
uh we'll we'll talk next week i'll have
this ready and we'll chat it up my man
good stuff there chris appreciate you
buddy
you guys